what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay you guys have been screaming at me
in the comments section to cover this
story and so we are going to originally
I was gonna upload a different story
today but we're actually gonna postpone
that till next week because it's not
nearly as important and we're gonna
cover the immortal Hulk now the immortal
Hulk is basically the return of Bruce
Banner as The Incredible Hulk in Marvel
Comics which his absence had really been
felt it was like the Fantastic Four not
being there right it's just kind of like
I mean you can't it was weird they
decided to kill him off during civil war
and then it was like I don't know why
you would like Wow like who thought that
was a good idea I guess it was been this
is a good idea now he's writing Superman
so we'll see how that plays out but uh
but nonetheless you know it's it's it's
cool to see The Incredible Hulk return
now what this does is this initially
picks up with a kid named Tommy and
Tommy actually knocks over a gas station
which is coincidentally run by rocks on
oil
oh those you guys don't know what Roxxon
Oil is it's like the most corrupt
organization in the entirety of Marvel
Comics they are they are your Marvel's
stand-in for your traditional corrupt
corporation they have their hands on
everything like slave trading and all
kind stuff there are a very very
sinister organization but Tommy busts
into this place and this robbery goes
exactly as you would expect because the
way this is done whenever it comes to
robbery there's only ever two kinds
there's basically people who are
confident about it people who have done
it before and those who are brand-new
Tommy is brand new to the whole to the
whole gas station robbery scene and you
could hear it you could tell by the way
its voice is going the fact that he's
trembling he's unsure of himself the guy
looks terrified me sweating and then
what happens is there's a young girl
named sandy who's in there she's 12
years old
and she drops a glass and when she does
Tommy freaks out and shoots her now this
happens directly in front of Bruce
Banner this leads to the incredible
whole beginning to manifest itself which
leads to Tommy shooting Bruce Banner in
the head now this is kind of an
important thing and the reason why is
because one of the arguments that people
make on how to kill the Incredible Hulk
it's to kill Bruce Banner this is
actually gonna answer that question and
it's gonna be a little bit of a trump
card that al Ewing throws in here in
order to bring the Incredible Hulk back
when Tommy takes off and he ends up you
know shooting the cashier and bails out
we end up picking up with the morgue
shortly after this now this does deal
with a detective named Gloria as well as
a reporter named Jackie it is kind of
cool because we're basically trying to
figure out who done this now initially
there's no real significance to them
right like Jackie's just a reporter
covering a story about a gas station
robbery and Gloria is a detective who's
you know trying to figure the whole
thing out but with regards to Bruce
Banner himself despite the fact that
he's essentially dead The Incredible
Hulk manifests itself now I want to say
this
like this happen during peter david's
run not gonna swear to it but as far as
i'm aware in the history of marvel
comics no rule of thumb when it came to
banners impending death and the
incredible hulk was that the hulk would
manifest right at the point when banner
was gonna die so if you go and you read
like The Incredible Hulk the end for
example banner throws himself off a
cliff and then the Incredible Hulk
manifest in order to save Banner this is
kind of a break from tradition the fact
that that Bruce Banner can basically be
dead can be diagonally be dead in an
autopsy you know prepared to be
performed and then sometime later
presumably maybe an hour later manifest
as The Incredible Hulk you never really
see that it's the way to just kind of
invoke invoke the Hulk and bring him
back and so what this does is this picks
up with a biker gang and this one we
realized the story's a little more
tragic than it originally appeared in
this sense that Tommy is actually in
debt to a biker gang just to keep the
lights on
quite literally like he's not really
able to pay the light bill he's got a
family to support he's doing whatever it
takes in order to make sure that they
have the resources they need and because
he's in debt to this biker gang he's
been knocking over gas stations in order
to pay back what he owes and so he's
basically like this guy who's caught in
an impossible situation now this leads
to the Incredible Hulk showing up and
basically massacring everybody and this
is exactly what you would expect I mean
none of them are prepared I mean is it's
it's just this giant green rage monster
showing up and just snatching people up
smashing their bones I mean bullets are
being sprayed in every direction and
none of it makes a difference because
where the guns are going off Tommy's
fleeing for his life people are
screaming and when the when when the
screaming stops then suddenly Tommy
turns around and he's basically he comes
face to face with the Incredible Hulk
himself and this is cool
because the way that a Ewing kind of
plays this out it's almost like a horror
film and that's really kind of what you
would expect with the Incredible Hulk
right like if you really get down to
like the great Incredible Hulk stories a
lot of them do focus on the Hulk himself
tearing things up and smashing things
because at the end of the day all
anybody really wants to see The
Incredible Hulk do is just smash stuff
it's not unreasonable that's why it's
catchphrases hooks smash because you
just want to see him destroy things I
guess that's what the Incredible Hulk
does you know but it's kind of
interesting because in this instance The
Incredible Hulk is almost merciless and
that's why I say this is like like I
mean savage Hulk will make his return in
storage but he's really very very dark
and merciless here because Tommy tries
to explain the situation and say look
you know I'm a guy who's caught in an
impossible situation you know that I
didn't mean for it to happen but at the
end today doesn't matter
the incredible hopes responses who cares
what your intention was you walk into a
gas station with a loaded gun you had no
idea what you were doing you pulled the
trigger out of desperation and panic and
you shot a twelve year old girl and
killer you my friend are in a world of
hurt and where where Tommy put you know
turns the gun on the Incredible Hulk and
shoots him it doesn't make a difference
and so we kind of asked this question he
says you know I'm not a bad guy am I in
the incredible response what do you
think and literally breaks every single
bone in his body and from the way it's
told a giant crater is left outside of a
hospital indicating it is the Incredible
Hulk just crumple Tommy like a piece of
paper just wanted him up and then took
him to the hospital and dropped him off
or he just threw him at the hospital and
just threw him into the ground
regardless of the scenario Tommy will
probably never walk again and he'll
probably never wake up again he's
essentially gonna be in a vegetative
state forever but will you have Gloria
and you have Jackie who are having a
conversation trying to figure out what's
going on Gloria and Jackie you're
friends and so Gloria ultimately spills
the beans and says look you didn't hear
this from me but the rumor here this
statement here at least from what we're
understanding from these bikers who have
confessed from the ones who were left
alive anyway the way this is being told
is that Tommy didn't do this that there
was somebody who showed up with an
insane amount of strength and he was
giant and he was green and that's when
they starts a debate they're like Bruce
Banner was shot and killed by Hawkeye
he's dead he's not supposed to be back
and they're like but yes he is though
there's really no denying this point as
an absolute truth that he really is back
and he really is alive and so it's kind
of interesting to see because you end up
having this this really cool scenario
where Jackie's going through and doing a
series of interviews you know talking to
various people getting a feel for their
stories about the Incredible Hulk and
basically all the stories they give is
that the Incredible Hulk is almost like
this this mythological being he's like
this mythological force that exists out
there that a lot of people have seen him
but it's like he's there and gone and
people don't walk up to him because
they're terrified and so in their
response in their mind it is this guy is
he's like a mythical beast that exists
out there but I'm not gonna tell you
anything about it it's like it's like
the old it's like the classic Sicilian
argument or a Sicilian statement for
like the Mafia right like I didn't see
anything because I wasn't home and if I
was home I still didn't see anything
because I was asleep like it's it's it's
really how this whole thing plays out
when it comes to like people who have
encountered him being terrified by a
couple people were kind of enamored and
that's why there's mixed stories here
because his stories like oh the
Incredible Hulk help people different
things like that so
it's a little bit fluctuating here now
from here we switch directly over to to
Jackie going through a research and so
on looking at these stories when she
suddenly met by Walter lankowski now
Walter link house key is a character
that we've never really talked about
before and we've never really had a
reason to but when it comes to the
character of Sasquatch he's been around
for a long long time the old alpha
flight story well really he goes all the
way back to uncanny x-men 120
I think way back in the day he goes back
to play seventh on now the idea behind
this here's kind of the cool thing the
idea behind the introduction of Walter
lankowski was that at the time going
really going all the way back to uncanny
x-men number 109 the idea was that the
there was an attempt that was made by
alpha flight which was Canada's a
superhero team that was monitored by the
government in Department H the idea was
that they wanted to bring Wolverine back
into the full because Wolverine had
previously been part of Alpha Flight and
what you had is you had Alpha Flight
traveling to try to find a way to kidnap
Wolverine and bring him back and that
really kind of led into a little more
fleshing out of Logan's backstory and
and so on and so forth but the way this
originally played out if you go back and
you read alpha flight issues 23 and 24
I'm not gonna swear by that although I
guess I should be right this is this
comic to explain ah if you go back and
you read the old alpha flight stories
the way it played out and really it's
kind of an origin that a Ewing runs over
again here it's not super important but
he kind of runs over again here the
notion was that Canada was looking for
its own version of the Incredible Hulk
basically because the first time the
Incredible Hulk showed up in Canada they
said well rain after him and really
Wolverine was defeated for the most part
so the question was okay they need their
own superhero team to defeat The
Incredible Hulk kind of an answer to
that version of his character and so you
ended up they ended up bringing in
sasquatch and they basically bombarded
Walter lankowski with gamma rays and
turned him into the Sasquatch character
the difference here is that back then in
the old alpha flight stories what you
had was basically a portal that would
open and so when Walter lankowski became
sasquatch what he was doing is he was
switching places with a beam called tan
Iraq now tan Iraq was one of these like
early beasts that existed in Marvel
Comics that was really like a different
dimension but always tried to invade
earth and over the years in Marvel
Comics released in the early days
running really throughout the nineteen
nineteen seventies in 1980s tanarak
would switch places so when Walter
lankowski became Sasquatch it would
allow for just a little more control
each time by tan Iraq until tan Iraq
seize control of Walter and took over
his body entirely now the resources led
to songbird basically destroying tan
Iraq but Henoch have been dead for a
long long time and that meant that it
was basically Walter who was always in
control whenever he became Sasquatch he
was always doing his own thing but he
was supremely strong he was incredibly
capable in his various abilities and of
course that led to him being one of the
many legitimate challengers for the
Incredible Hulk
now where you end up having like this
bar fight that breaks out basically
between Walter lankowski and like a
whole bunch of crazy guys this of course
leads to him being stabbed which leads
to him going to the hospital in and of
himself this is not wildly important the
reason why this matters is because one
ends up happening here is Bruce Banner
goes and speaks directly to Jackie and
when she does he basically tells her
this whole thing is happening in the
middle of the night the clock is about
to strike midnight and when that happens
he's gonna turn into sasquatch again
when he does turn into sasquatch it will
not be Walter lankowski use and control
it'll be the other guy and because Bruce
Banner doesn't really know about the
idea that tanarak is no longer part of
the picture in his mind he believes Tana
rock will be the one to seize control
and so that's what he tells Jackie you
have to evacuate the hospital you have
to get everybody out of here because if
you don't everybody's going to die and
that's when Walter begins to sort of
retransform again because the kind of
push to the next phase and then suddenly
he ends up just having his baby really
just kind of takes on this form that is
almost identical to the old tanarak
character and so it was kind of crazy
because it seems like Han Iraq is
essentially back now this leads into a
massive fight between the two groups
when really the Incredible Hulk takes
over and goes through and just starts
tearing everything up now Bruce Banner
is the one who tries to approach Walter
and try to talk to reason into him but
this is when you know tanarak basically
like slashes Bruce banners throat and
says you know I don't want to talk to
you I want to talk to the other guy so
Bruce Banner basically manifested in the
Incredible Hulk and the two of them
start going at it now this is when
things get cool because on the surface
we would write this off as just a
retelling of the old 1970s Incredible
Hulk stories with like The Incredible
Hulk vs. our vs. sasquatch and that
would be it what happens as Al Ewing
actually switches it up and where you
end up having him believing like we ends
up asking the question are you possessed
by like Mephisto or tanarak or something
like that the response here is I'm
neither of those guys I'm the person
you're terrified of the most and we end
up finding out the want the body of
Walter Walter link house key is actually
possessed by the father by Brian Banner
the father of Bruce
those are guys who don't know what a
constant Bruce banners character over
the years a hallmark of his character
was that he was he was the child of an
abusive father but a lot of that really
comes out of like bill Mantlo and Peter
David's runs of the Incredible Hulk
because back then in those stories they
fleshed out the idea that like The
Incredible Hulk persona was a result of
like all the torment guilt in and and
hatred and rage that Bruce Banner felt
being victimized by his father so
frequently and so his father played a
major role in the stories especially
under Peter David but when you're
talking about those two runs being
combined it caused all kinds of crazy
situations and it really introduced some
really cool concept in terms of how
Bruce Banner viewed his father and how
he viewed himself but where you end up
having Bruce Banner walking around with
like a victim's mindset and really
almost like kind of panics for a moment
he basically starts lashing out but what
is up happening his Incredible Hulk kind
of splits the difference right he sits
down and he says you know in a matter of
seconds you know in his own mind he sits
down and he says Bruce banners the one
that's afraid of his father I'm The
Incredible Hulk I'm not afraid of
anybody
The Incredible Hulk is the strongest
there is and this is when he makes the
switch and and the Incredible Hulk
stops being Incredible Hulk and turns
back into savage Hulk and when he does
he absolutely goes toe-to-toe with
sasquatch I remember sasquatch was the
design to be the Canadian version of the
Incredible Hulk - the unlimited strength
and so Sasquatch is able to readily hold
his own and does quite well I mean
literally you have you know Brian Banner
in the body of Walter doing exactly what
he does and in ripping them apart the
difference here is that Brian Banner did
not count on the one thing that we
almost never see from The Incredible
Hulk
The Incredible Hulk response being I eat
gamma radiation when it comes to the
Incredible Hulk because he consumes
gamma radiation anything that that emits
gamma radiation he can essentially feed
off of you're basically putting him in
front of a buffet and because of the
fact that Sasquatch is bombarded with
gamma radiation the Incredible Hulk
basically absorbs the entire Sasquatch
persona unto himself and then in turn
leaves Walter lankowski with no powers
whatsoever and so what he ends up doing
is speaking directly to Jackie herself
and this is kind of cool he asked Jackie
the question he said you're a local
reporter in some small town somewhere
but you've decided to follow me all the
way here so the question I have is why
are you here what are you looking for
and Jackie's response is I want to be
like you like I want to have the power
that you have I want to be a version of
The Incredible Hulk now of course this
leads to the
basically walking away and saying go
home do your own thing but it's kind of
crazy because it introduces the idea
that someone is intentionally chasing
after to becoming the Incredible Hulk
which is not something you normally see
but where you end up having Walter
lankowski saying like the Sasquatch
persona is gone it's no longer a part of
him anymore
when Bruce Banner is basically walking
away it's it's essentially this really
cool idea where Al Ewing does a
throwback to the old Peter David and
bill Mantlo stories where the Incredible
Hulk has reabsorbed the personality of
his father he's reabsorbed his father's
ghost and so this is one of those things
where it returns to the old style of
Incredible Hulk storytelling back when
it was more character-driven where you
basically had the Incredible Hulk
dealing with the torment of his father
giving him all kinds of Hell and
wreaking havoc inside of his head but
would that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here - comments explained make sure
you guys at the sub button - become part
of the rod poor if you guys enjoy this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]
you